مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه
والبدايه بالعناوين
بعد سته ايام على وقوع الكارثه حصيله
ضحايا زلزال كهرمان مراش في تركيا وسوريا
تقارب
26,000
الامم المتحده تصف الكارثه بالاسوا في
المنطقه منذ مئه عام ومارتن جريفيث يقول
ان مرحله الانقاذ تقترب من نهايتها
وتقارير عن تسجيل نحو 70 هزه ارتداديه على
امتداد اليوم
تفاقم القلق
مع دخول عمليات الانقاذ مرحله حاسمه فرق
الانقاذ تنجح في اخراج ناجين من تحت
الانقاض في مدن تركيا تحقيقات واعتقالات
في مناطق متضرره على خلفيه اتهامات بغش في
البناء والسلطات تقول ان ترحيل المنكوبين
اهم الاولويات
اردوغان يعيد باستكمال اعاده الاعمار في
غضون عام
سته ايام على الكارثه وما زال سعي حفيفا
للوصول الى الناجين والصامدين تحت الانقاض
في تركيا وعلى الرغم من التوقيت الحاسم
يفرض بعض الخارجين من تحت الارض معادله
الامل كطفل رضيع ينجو بعد خمسه ايام دون
شيء لا طعام ولا دفء ومن دون امه السعي لا
يسير بالوتيره ذاتها في مناطق الشمال
السوري يقول الدفاع المدني هناك انه اوقف
عمليات البحث عن ناجين فما في اليد
قدم خلال الايام الماضيه والمعاول بايديهم
اصغر من هول الكارثه وعلى وقع هذا التصريح
يعلو جدل المساعدات اكثر فاكثر لعل حظ
الناجين يكون افضل ممن قضوا تحت الارض
حصيله قتل الزلزال في تركيا تجاوزت 22,000
بالاضافه الى اكثر من 80 الف جريح اما في
سوريا فقد اقترب عدد القتلى من خمسه الاف
بالاضافه الى اكثر من 80 الف جريح ومع
تضاؤل فرص العثور على ناجين يتوقع ان
يرتفع عدد القتلى في البلدين نظرا لوجود
اعداد كبيره من الضحايا تحت الانقاض
وتستمر فرق الاغاثه في انقاذ نجينا بعضهم
قضى اكثر من 130 ساعه تحت الانقاض في
كهرمان مرعش يتم انقاذ سيده في السبعين من
عمرها بعد 121 ساعه من وقوع الزلزال وخلال
انقاذ اسره مؤلفه من خمسه اشخاص يصر الاب
على اخراج كل افراد اسرته قبل اخراجه وفي
انطاكيا انقذ طفل يبلغ من العمر شهرين
وتمكنت فرق الاغاثه من انقاذ طفله عمرها
عامان وسيده حامل في شهرها السادس وطفله
تبلغ من العمر اربع سنوات مع والديها ما
ابقى الامل في انقاذ اخرين قائما رغم مرور
الوقت
المشهد في سوريا مختلف قليلا فقد اعلن
الدفاع المدني في الشمال السوري انتهاء
عمليات الانقاذ وانتقد ما سماه التقصير
والتاخير في ارسال المساعدات الى
المنكوبين في المنطقه تقول الامم المتحده
ان خمسه ملايين الف سوري اصبحوا بلا ماوى
بعد الزلزال وامام صعوبه ايصال المساعدات
الى المنطقه والظروف الجويه تتخوف
المنظمات الانسانيه من انتشار الامراض
والاوبئه
تقول الامم المتحده انها ستطلق نداء من
اجل عمليه اغاثه لتقديم مساعدات لضحايا
الزلزال تستمر ثلاثه اشهر
وتتوقع منظمات انسانيه ان تستمر الحاجه
لهذه المساعدات اكثر من سنه ففي تركيا
وحدها قال الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ان عدد
المتضررين في المناطق المنكوبه قد يصل الى
20 مليون مواطن اما في سوريا فقد اعلنت
الامم المتحده ان 5 ملايين و300 الف سوري
اصبحوا بلا ماوى بسبب الزلزال واعلنت وحده
تنسيق الدعم التابعه للاعتلاف السوري
المعارض ان هناك حاجه ل 13 الف خيمه
لايواء المتضررين بسبب انهيار
1700 بنايه
[موسيقى]
كيف لا يحتفى بالحياه هي هنا حياه عائشه
الفتاه التركيه الخارجه الينا من تحت
الانقاذ
مثلها كتبت النجاه لذاك الطفل الرضيع
[موسيقى]
وللفتى بمثال 13 اردجان
الساعات الطوال الثقال على المنقذين
ومنقذيهم قد تفضي اذا الى ما يهون المصاب
وفي وقائعك هذه حتما ما يبث املا في نفوس
من لا زال ينتظرون عوده قريب مفقود
واضح ان العمل القائم في مركز الزلزال
الاسوء في المنطقه منذ قرن تعززه امكانات
البحث والانقاذ التركيه والدعم القادم
اليها من الخارج
ليت الامر كذلك وراء الحدود الجنوبيه
يعلم السوريون في المناطق المنكوبه
بالزلزال ان ليس لهم غير الله كما قالوا
هدوما من سيلومون على جعل معدات الانقاذ
والاسعاف الحيويه حلما بعيدا المنال
لم نتلقى اي شيء عبر الحدود الى حد اللحظه
لا فرق انقاذ ولا تجهيزات طبيه ولا غذاء
بعد خمسه ايام من الزلزال اننا نحتاج الى
اغاثه غذائيه وعلاجيه وايواء عاجلا غير
اجل
لا ينشغل الناس هنا في الشمال السوري
المنكوب بالمسؤوليات التي تتقاذفها
الاطراف عن التقصير والتاخير
يبقيهم هنا الامل في ان ثمه انفاسا تحت
هذا الركام لم تنقطع
لكن العجز يتملكهم بعد الانتقال الى
عمليات البحث والانتشال فالخوض البيض تخرج
من الجثث اكثر مما تعثره على ناجين يمضي
الوقت ومعه تفرض الحكمه تحويل الاهتمام
كله نحو الناجين ممن شردهم الزلزال
[موسيقى]
اولئك بحاجه الى ايواء واعاشه وذاك وعد
اخر اخلفه كما يبدو جل الواعدين
انضموا الينا من غزه عنتاب مراسل الجزيره
منتصر ابو نبوت ومن اعزاز فيري في حلب
مراسل الجزيره محمد الجزائري
ونبدا معك
منتصر ماذا يمكن ان يقال عن عمليات
الانقاذ طوال هذا اليوم وما جديدها في هذا
المساء
فرق الانقاذ على التتبع المزيد من الاشخاص
تحت الانقاذ وتوصلوا الى يعني بعد الحفر
الى ثلاثه اشخاص
وتبين ان هذه الاشخاص الثلاثه قد قد قضوا
وبعد ان اخرجوا الجثث امامنا وان وضعوا
الستاره لكي لا يرى احد هذه الجثث حتى
يضعها في في اكياس بلون اسود كان هنالك
جثه صغيره يبدو انها لطفل او لطفله
قضت تحت الانقاذ ايضا شاهدنا حاله من
البكاء لفرق الانقاذ الذين يعني شاهدوا
هذا المنظر ولانه لم يتمكنوا من انقاذ
الجميع بالرغم انهم عملوا بوسعهم خلال
الايام الماضيه ايضا هنا بالقرب من من هذا
المبنى يوجد مبنى اخر انتهت به اعمال
البحث وانتقلت فرق الانقاذ الى مواقع اخرى
في مدينه غازي عنتاب لمسانده زملائهم في
الا الاخرى والابنيه المستعصيه التي
يحاولون فيها البحث عن المزيد من الناجين
اريد هنا ان نتحدث اكثر عن مدينه
الاصلاحيه هذه المدينه عندما دخلناها كانت
مدينه مدمره بالكامل فاطمه شاهين رئيسه
بلديه غازي عنتاب كانت قد قالت ان اكثر من
نصف المنازل في هذه المدينه دمرت وفعلا
لما ذهبنا الى هناك المدينه مدمره تماما
الجيش التركي يتولى حمايه هذه المدينه
ويعمل على الانقاذ مع فرق الانقاذ ومسانده
هذه الفرق وايضا يعمل على حمايه الممتلكات
في هذه المدينه وايضا شاهدنا مخيما كبيرا
على ما يبدو ان كل سكان مدينه الاصلاحيه
الذي يبلغ عددهم نحو 60,000 قد ذهبوا الى
هذه المخيمات ومنهم من غادر الى خارج
مدينه غازي عنتاب بعد هذا الحادث المؤلم
بعد هذا الزلزال الذي يعني يعتبر كارثه
بالنسبه لاهالي المنطقه كلهم الذين يعني
يتعرضوا لهذا زلزال سوى في تركيا
في شمال سوريا
طيب هذا في في غازي عنتاب ومدن تلك
الولايه ماذا عن اعزاز وريف حلب مع اعلان
الدفاع المدني السوري بان عمليات الانقاذ
قد انتهت عمليا بعدما قدم ما قدم وهذا
اقصى ما يمكن تقديمه ماذا بعد محمد
نعم حسن هذا الاعلان كان وقعوه كبيرا جدا
وقاسيا جدا على الاهالي الذين ينتظرون في
محيط مواقع الابنيه المدمره في امكان في
مدينه جنديرس او في مناطق اخرى
ادلب باضافه الى مواقع عده محيط في القرى
المحيطه في مدينه جنديرس هذا الخبر كان
وقعه قاسيا جدا على الاهالي الاهالي الذين
ينتظرون بفارغ الصبر معلومات عن ابنائهم
وذويهم لكنهم تحت الانقاض الذين ينتظرون
خبر من الدفاع المدني على انهم احياء او
سمع اقل ما يمكن اصواته من تحت الالقاب
ولكن هذا الخبر كان حاسم وكان يعني اتخذه
الدفاع المدني واعلنه وكان هذا اتخاذ
القرار هذا من الدفاع المدني مرتبطا
بعوامل كثيره قله المعدات قله الفرق
الامكانيات عدم دخول اي فرق من عبر الحدود
للمساهمه والمساعده
ومساعده على التسريع في عمليه انقاذ ليكون
هناك الفرص في الحياه اكبر لعالقين تحت
انقاذ حقيقه نحن نتحدث عن ارقام كبيره من
الابنيه المدمره ومواقع كثيره
المتضرره واعداد كبيره جدا للمتظرين وحتى
الذين هم تحت الانقاض الى الان ولكن بات
الواقع صعب جدا بعد مرور خمسه ايام على
هذا الزلزال
والرقام المدن وركام الابنيه هناك امنيه
لم يصل اليها الدفاع المدني ولم يبدا
العمل فيها حتى هذه اللحظه لكثره المواقع
ولكن كل ما هنالك الفرق الاهليه والاهالي
يحاولون رفع الاسقف ويرفع الاعمده
الميتونيه للوصول ومحاوله الوصول الى
الشقق السكنيه والغرف التي كان يقطنها
ذويهم للبحث عنها ولكن هذه هذا الامر صعب
جدا ومستحيل من دون اي اليات ثقيله الدفاع
الدفاع المدني الذي تشتت في كل هذه النق
ولكن لم يستطيع العمل الا بالمتاح لديه
طيب فقط لنفهم ماذا يعني توقف عمليات
الانقاذ هل يعني ذلك بان العمل سيتوقف
كليا ام انه فقد الامل بوجود احياء
وبالتالي يمكن ازاله الانقاذ
بطريقه عشوائيه اذا صح التعبير بما انه لن
يكون هناك
مزيد من الاحياء كما يتوقع
نعم حسن في الحقيقه الانتقال من مرحله
البحث والانقاذ الى مرحله البحث والانتشار
هناك فرق بالبدايه كانت الفرق الدفاع
المدني تقوم بالبحث والتانين بالبحث ورفع
الانقراض ببطء ومعرفه تفحص تحت هذه العقاب
ومحاوله سماع الاصوات
وتتبع المواقع التي كانت فيها الاهالي عبر
الجيران الناجمه تحت الانقاض لمعرفه تجمع
الاهالي للوصول بكل دقه الى
الناجين والاشخاص الذين تحت نقاط بالاضافه
الى الحفر
باليات اليدويه واستخدام الاليات الثقيله
بدقه وحذر وخبرات الدفاع المدني ولكن
المرحله الان مرحله البحث والانتشار هي
بدات برفع نقاط
وليست بطريقه عشوائيه ولكن بطريقه
قد لا تراعي وجود
الناجين تحت هذه القاب مع هذه المده عمليه
اسرع من عمليه البحث والانقاذ والتاني
فيها ستكون عمليه سريعه لانتشال الركام
والنقل الى من مكان الى مكان وتفحص شيئا
فشيئا ربما الاليات الثقيله تقوم بنقل
دفعات من الركام المنازل ومن ثم تكون
الفرقه الاخرى تبحث في هذا المكان لتنتقل
وتتابع شيئا فشيئا للوصول الى الجثث
والاشخاص الذين قضوا تحت هذه انقاذ ولكن
حقيقه هذا الامر كان صعب جدا على الاهالي
الذين ما ينتظرون سماع خبر
ساعود الى منتصر للحديث عن هذه النقطه مع
منتصر ابو نبوت في غازي عنتاب بما انه كما
تابعنا هناك قصص ما زالت
تروى وما زالت تظهر يوميا عن اطفال عن
رجال او نساء او حتى عائلات قضوا اكثر من
100 ساعه تحت الانقاض ولكن يتم انقاذهم
وهم على قيد الحياه
هذه الحالات المستمره يمكن ان تؤجل
الانتقال الى المرحله الثانيه مرحله رفع
الانقاض وتسريع رفع الانقاض
حسن هنالك فرق ما بين سوريا وتركيا من حيث
المعدات الموجوده
والطرق المستخدمه في عمليه الانقاذ هنا
اليوم شاهدنا مثلا كلبا مدرب على ان يكتشف
البشر تحت الانقاض او غير ذلك او الاشخاص
الذين يتحركون وكان يذهب و يعني يفرق
الانقاذ تقلي المكان له ويذهب ثم يبدا
وبعد ذلك يعطي اشاره الى المكان الذي
يعتقد انه يوجد فيها شخص ايضا ايضا لديهم
تقنيات متعلقه بالكاميرات التي يتم
انزالها الى ما بين الانقاذ
والتصوير لمعرفه اين هذا الشخص او اي اي
كيف يوجد او اي في اي مكان او الطريقه
التي هو موجود فيها حتى يفهموا ويعرفوا
كيف سيستمر بعمليه البحث وايضا هذا يعني
هذه كل كل هذه الامور تعطي فرصه اكبر لذلك
هم سيستمرون عمليه البحث
والانتشار يعني انهم لن يبداوا بعمليه
الازاله العشوائيه حتى يتاكدوا من ان كل
مبنى هو مبنى فارغ هذا يعني بحسب ما يعني
فهمناه من احد رجال الانقاذ اليوم الذي
تحدثنا معه والذي ابلغنا عن بعض المعلومات
المتعلقه في احد المواقع قال نحن لا نفقد
الامل قال لي نحن لا نفقد الامل وانما
نستمر بعمليه البحث حتى اخر لحظه
بكاء هؤلاء الاشخاص عندما اخرجوا امامي
ثلاثه جثث خرجت امامي اصبحوا يبكون بكاءهم
يعني يؤكد انهم لا يريدون ان يبحثوا
بطريقه عشوائيه لن يكون لديهم العزيمه
ليبحثوا بطريقه عشوائيه بل انهم سيستمرون
على هذه الحاله على امل ان ان يخرج احد
على قيد الحياه كما حصل اليوم وكما حصل
امس وكما حصل منذ بدايه هذه هذه الكارثه
شكرا لك منتصر ابو نبوت من غازي عنتاب
شكرا لمحمد الجزائري من اعزاز في ريف حلب
السعير المستمر اذا للوصول الى ناجين ومنذ
وقوع الكارثه تنقسم جهود الاستجابه
للتعامل مع ما بعدها الى ثلاث مراحل
رئيسيه تبدا الاولى بمحاوله الوصول الى
العليقين باسرع وقت ممكن
وتنتهي بازاله اثار الركام والانقاد
للتعرف اكثر على تفاصيل تلك المراحل نتابع
التقرير التالي
بعد لحظات الزلزال العصيبه تتركز الجهود
في المرحله الاولى للاستجابه للكارثه على
البحث عن الناجين وانقاذ العدد الاكبر من
الارواح يستعان في ذلك بمجموعه من المعدات
تعجل بالوصول لاماكن العالقين تحت الانقاض
وفجوات الركام مثل نظام دار القادر على
رصد الاجسام الثابته والمتحركه عبر
الخرسانه المسلحه ومعدات الصوت الحساسه
والكاميرات الحراريه وايضا الكلاب المدربه
تستمر هذه المرحله ما بين خمسه الى سبعه
ايام
ارتضضاء الو فرص العثور على احياء بعد ذلك
لكن استمرار البحث عن المتبقي من الناجين
واستمرارا انتشال جثامين الضحايا ودفنهم
قد يستمر لايام اطول ثم تاتي مرحله
الاغاثه الطارئه تتوجه الجهود هنا نحو
تقديم المساعده العاجله لمن شردتهم كارثه
وتشمل تامين الماوى المؤقت وتوفير الماء
والغذاء اضافه الى رعايه طبيه والاسعافات
الاوليه مده هذه المرحله تطول او تقصر
بحسب حجم المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال
والامكانات المتاحه لفرق الاغاثه بعد ذلك
ينتقل الى المرحله الاخيره مرحله التعافي
التي تبدا بايجاد ماوى للعائلات المنكوبه
يكون قادرا على تحمل الظروف الجويه
كالامطار والرياح مع توفر امكانيه الوصول
للمياه والغذاء ليتم الانتقال بعد ذلك الى
فحص المباني المتضرره وازاله الخطر منها
ثم العمل على ازاله الركام والانقاض
والبدء باصلاح شبكات الصرف الصحي والمياهي
والكهرباء وقد تستمر هذه المرحله سنوات
للتخلص من كافه اثار الزلزال
[موسيقى]
انا من مدينه هاتاي باليت تشديمير المتحدث
باسم المؤسسه التركيه للبحث والانقاذ
مرحبا بك الان في اي مرحله تكون
مراحل البحث والانقاذ
والاغاثه في في تركيا لضحايا ومن كوبي
الزلزال في اي مرحله الان
مرحله البحث والانقاذ لا تزال قائمه ولكن
طبعا عدد الناجين سوف يتراجع تدريجيا وهذا
امر طبيعي لان الناس علقوا تحت الركام
لحوالي سته ايام
وبالاضافه الى ذلك البرد قارس
والحراره تنخفض بشكل كبير في خلال ساعات
الليل وبالتالي مع اننا لا نزال في مرحله
البحث والانقاذ الان ولكن عدد الناجين
يتراجع وبالتالي شرفنا على الانتهاء من
هذه المرحله
ولكن يعني صحيح كما تقول شرفتم على
الانتهاء ولكن كيف يمكن ان نفسر تلك
الحالات ولو انها فرديه ومنقطعه من مكان
الى اخر ولكن هذه الحالات ما زالت موجوده
حتى للاطفال يعني بقوا على قيد الحياه من
دون ماء ولا طعام وفي ظل ظروف مناخيه صعبه
رغم ذلك تم انقاذهم
الاطفال
حجمهم صغير وبالتالي
يمكنهم ان يكونوا في الاماكن الضيقه
والحراره يمكن ان يحافظ عليها في هذه
الاماكن الضيقه بشكل اكبر والبشر يمكنهم
ان يبقوا من دون الطعام
وحتى الماء لبعض الايام وفي بعض الاحيان
يتراكم الجليد ويتحول الى ماء ويصل الى
بعض الاشخاص وكما قلت الاطفال يمكنهم ان
ينجوا بهذه الطريقه طيب فيما فيما يتعلق
بعمليات
الانقاذ والبحث
يعني متى يمكن ان تبدا المرحله الثانيه
والتي يفترض ان تكون اسرع كما فهمنا منك
المرحله الثانيه اذا ما كنا نتحدث عن
مرحله
التي تلي مرحله الانقاذ تاريخيا البحث
والانقاذ تستمر حتى سبعه الى تسعه ايام
وهناك بعض الايام التي تفصلنا عن انتهاء
هذه المرحله وبعد ذلك نصل الى المرحله
الثانيه في اليوم العاشر او اليوم الحادي
عشر الان ما هي الصعوبات التي ما زالت
تواجهكم والى اي مدى الوضع افضل من الايام
الاولى
يمكننا ان نتحدث عن سلسله من الامور في
اليوم الاول
كان الناس ليس لديهم فهم كامل لحجم
الكارثه هناك زلازل وهزات ارضيه حصلت في
تركيا في الماضي عاده يكون هناك منطقه
مدينه او حي سكني ولكن للمره الاولى نرى
هذا الامتداد الواسع للدمار على منطقه
جغرافيه كبيره في البدايه لم نكن نعرف مدى
انتشار هذا الدمار وتدريجيا بدانا ان نفهم
هذه الامور وهناك تحديات برزت على مستوى
التنسيق هناك حاجه الى التنسيق مع الفرق
من اماكن مختلفه من تركيا بالاضافه الى
الفرق الدوليه وبالتالي اليه التنسي
وصلنا اليها بعد ذلك بمرحله وذلك بسبب
انتشار الواسع للدمار الان وقد مرت ايام
على هذه الكارثه التنسيق يجري على قدر
وساق بشكل افضل ولكن في الوقت نفسه هناك
تعب شديد على مستوى
العاملين في مجال البحث والانقاذ
والمساعده وايضا هناك الحراره المنخفضه
والطقس البارد وبالتالي نحن نشارف على
الانتهاد على الانتهاء من مرحله البحث
والانقاذ هناك تعب ليس فقط على مستوى
الجسدي بل ايضا على المستوى النفسي وفي
الوقت نفسه هناك توقعات من السكان طبعا
هذا حقهم ان يتوقعوا من ان
ينتشل تنتشر الفرق
هناك مزيج من التعب وايضا من التعامل مع
التوقعات
[موسيقى]
اتيت على ذكر فرق الانقاذ الدوليه
والاقليميه التي
توافدت الى تركيا للمساعده الى اي مدى كان
لها دور حاسم في بعض المناطق في تسريع
عمليات البحث والانقاذ
اعتقد ان هذا العامل كان حاسما للغايه كما
سبق وقلت في مقابلات سابقه وحتى في هذه
المقابله نحن نتحدث عن منطقه تقريبا بحجم
انجلترا
وطالها الزلزال وبالتالي هناك
استجابه حصلت على مستوى الحكومه التركيه
وعلى مستوى المنظمات غير الحكوميه ولكن من
الصعوبه بمكان ان يتم التجهيز للتعامل مع
زلزالا بهذا المستوى لذلك الاستجابه
الدوليه والفرق الدوليه لعبت دورا اساسيا
للتخفيف من هذه التحديات وهناك بعض
المناطق التي لم تتمكن الفرق المحليه من
الوصول اليها بعدم استعدادها وتدريبها
ولكن بسبب عدم اتاحه الكافيه وبالتالي
الفرق الدوليه ساعدتنا في تغطيه المنطقه
الاوسع شكرا جزيلا لك بلد تشديمير المتحدث
باسم المؤسسه التركيه للبحث والانقاذ
حدثتنا من
تواصل عمليات البحث والانقاذ في عده
ولايات تركيه وتوقفها في ولايات اخرى
نستعرض عدد عناصر البحث والانقاذ ومن اين
جاؤوا
وصلت تركيا اكثر من 730 عنصرا يعملون في
البحث والانقاذ قدموا من 61 دوله مباشره
انتشروا في المناطق المنكوبه العدد الاكبر
من هؤلاء ذهب الى ولايه هاتاي التي وصلها
قرابه 2400 عنصر ثم ولايه كهرمان مراش
مركز الزلزال التي استقبلت اكثر من 1600
عنصر تليها ولايه اديمان حيث وصلها اكثر
من 1500 عنصر اعداد اقل
ذهبت الى غازي عنتاب وملاطيه وعثمانيه
تتوقع تركيا وصول اكثر من 2100 عنصر بحث
وانقاذ اجنبي هذه الطواقم جاءت من عشرات
الدول التي عرضت المساعده على تركيا
هول الغياب تحت الارض والمعارك مع الامل
في الخروج على قيد الحياه قصص لناجين من
الزلزال في اليمن التركيه قابلتهم مراسلات
الجزيره سلام خضر واعدت التقرير التالي
يعني فوق الارض
ليتمسك من هو عالق تحتها بخيط
حياه
[تصفيق]
ايام تمر وناجون ينهضون من تحت الابنيه
المنهاره هنا يشيرون اليها بالمعجزات
يرشدنا فرحات الى مبنى انهار على ساكنيه
وهو كان منهم بقي عالقا تحت الركام نحو
ثلاثه عشره ساعه ساعه
مروعه كان يسمع خلالها اصوات اقاربه
سنشتغل
ولم يسمعني احد رغم انني كنت اسمع الضجيج
في الخارج اللهم انحني القوه للصمود وان
اخرج حيا انها معجزه وفقدت تحت الانقاض
شقيقي وشقيقتي في موقع قريب يحاول الرجال
الانقاذ سحب شخص من تحت الانقاض لا نعرف
ان كان على قيد الحياه
قصص ملهمه شهدنا عليها في زلزال كهرمان
مراش دفعتنا الى التساؤل ما الذي يساعد
الانسان على البقاء على قيد الحياه وسط
مشهد الدمار الكبير هذا وانعدام فرص
الحياه تحت الانقاض واستمرار الهزات
الارتداديه والبرد الشديد حملنا السؤال
الى فريق انقاذ مختص بالتعامل مع العالقين
الاحياء تحت الانقاض حجم المكان حيث يوجد
الشخص الناجي وشده الاصابه من العوامل
التي تلعب دورا في الصمود تحت الانقاض
ليبقى الجفاف هو التهديد الاخطر
محظوظين لاننا في الشتاء والطقس بارد وهذا
ما يبقي الاشخاص على قيد الحياه لمده اطول
بخلاف البلدان الاستوائيه والحاره حيث
يصعب البقاء على قيد الحياه لاكثر من
ثلاثه ايام مشاهد جويه تظهر جزءا من حجم
الدمار العظيم الذي لحق بادي يمان
التقديرات الاوليه تش
من هاتاي معنا محمود تملي مسؤول ملف اداره
الازمه في وقف الديانات التركيه سيد محمود
مرحبا بك واضح انك تحدثنا من داخل السياره
وانت في خضن عملك نشكرك على الوقت الذي
تعطيه لنا الان ولكن نود ان نسالك اولا عن
المهمه الموكله اليكم حاليا وما الذي
تقومون به وفي اي مجال باداره هذه الازمه
الكبرى
جزاكم الله خير نحن طبعا في بدايه له
ساعات بدانا ان نستغل اول
الوظيفه كان لدينا توصيل مساعدات
انسانيه الى هذه المناطق الذي تعرفونه
جميعا وهذه الان بدانا الى مرحله ثانيه
لنزور المناطق كله هو حاليا نحن كما
تعرفون نحن كما رايتم نحن في الطريق زرنا
اسكندرون اجرنا والان رايحين في الطريق
الى ريحانيه وبعد ذلك نريد ان يعني
المرحله الاولى الطارئه ونعم المرحله
الثانيه ما هو المرحله الثانيه توصيل
مساعدات انسانيه الى القرى
المتضرره وبعيده عن المساعدات في الذي
ياتي الى المراكز هذه المرحله الثانيه
بنفس الوقت هناك وجدت بدا ان يظهر يعني
حاجات الناقصه
ممكن منسيه يعني
التثبيت
احتياجات جديده
وتوصيله في المرحله الثانيه الى المناطق
المنكوبه ما هي ما هي تلك المساعدات التي
يحتاجونها الان المنكوبون بشكل ملح الان
ماذا يحتاجون اكثر ما يحتاجون اليه
يعني اليوم ضمن ثلاثه نقاط يعني المس
الحاجه الذي يذكر حاليا هو
الايواء يعني يطلبون الناس
والمناطق هو القيم او الكرفانات
وتفريش
الداخلي هذا والتدفئه طبعا كما تعرفون نحن
في الشتاء
ايواء تفويش الايواء التدفئه هذا نراه
حاليا الناقص فينا طيب هل مع تدفق
المساعدات الى تركيا هل اصبحت هذه
المساعدات تكفي او تفي بالحاجه الملحه على
الاقل الان
على الاقل نعم نستطيع ان نقول يعني لان
هذه المرحله اولى نعم الان حالات ضروريه
بدا المصفف ولكن هذه الفتره يعني هذه
المرحله سيستمر هذه الوضع سيستمر
يعني هذا يحتاج الى الاستمرار ايضا لا
نستطيع ان نقول حاجه انتهى ونقطع نعم ولكن
الضروره نعم
نستطيع ان نقول ان الضروره خففت علينا
هل انتم من ينسخ بشكل مباشر مع المؤسسات
الاهليه الاقليميه والدوليه التي تقدم
المساعدات ام فقط انتم تتلقونها من جهات
رسميه تركيه
نحن نتعامل في نقوم بالعمل في تقريبا 150
دوله هناك يوجد شركاء لوقت ديانه التركي
في عده دول وهذه الشركائنا الان نحن عندنا
التنسيق عالي معهم
لادخال
الفرق من طرفهم ومساعدتهم الى المناطق
المنسوبه يعني عندنا هناك يوجد
دعم دعم لا ياتي من مجتمع تركي
ومؤسسات الدوليه من كل الدول العالم
من هاتاي محمود تملي مسؤول ملف اداره
الازمه في وقف الديانات التركيه شكرا
جزيلا لك
في سوريا الان الامل تراجعت بالعثور على
مزيد من الناجين تحت انقاذ بيوتهم في
مناطق شمال غرب البلاد بعد خمسه ايام
اعقبت الزلزله المدمر واتسمت بشح يقترب من
العدم في المساعدات الاقليميه والدوليه
كان متحدثون باسم منظمات انسانيه محليه
وعالميه قد طالبوا دون جدوى بتزويد فرق
الانقاذ في شمال السوري بالادوات والوسائل
والمعدات الضروريه لعمليات البحث عن
الناجين وانتشال الضحايا من تحت الركام
تقرير ماجد عبد الهادي
يا الله اني اتهم جمله قصيره يستلها
السوريون الان من روايات الظلم في التاريخ
الانساني ليكتبها ومعها عبارات اخرى
ترادفها معنى على صفحات ماساتهم او
ليرددوها باصواتهم المخنوقه تحت وفوق ركام
بيوتهم التي دمرها الزلزال وقد قطع كثيرون
منهم الشك اخيرا في تخاذل المجتمع الدولي
عن واجب انقاذهم بيقين تواطئه ضدهم
للروايه هنا صيغتان اولاهما تفترض فصل
الانساني عن السياسي لتدعو الى مساعده
المنكوبين باعتبارهم ضحايا كارثه طبيعيه
وفي معزل عن كل ما سبقها من صراعات بين
نظام الحكم والثائرين عليه بينما تتحدث
الثانيه عن سياق من الكوارث السياسيه التي
القت بملايين السوريين بين انياب الزلزال
الجيولوجي وليس من الحكمه تجاهلها عند
الحديث عن وجهه عمليات الاغاثه
كان لابد والحال هذه من الم الانتظار
بكلفته البشريه الباهظه حتى يكتمل سيناريو
الاحداث على ارض الواقع ويصل الى نتيجته
الفاجعه التي قد لا تختلف عليها الروايات
في اليوم الاول وقع الزلزال المدمر وتحدثت
الانباء عن ضحايا باعداد من خانتين او
ثلاث في اليوم الثاني صارت الخانات اربعه
وفي الثالث هبت عشرات الدول لارسال فرق
الاغاثه الى تركيا ثم في الرابع بدا
المنكوبون في شمال غرب سوريا يدركون ان
مناطقهم مستثناه من رافت العالم التزاما
بقرارات سابقه كانت توافقت عليها الدول
الكبرى في الامم المتحده حول طرق ارسال
المعونات اليهم ومع حلول اليوم الخامس
تعالت التساؤلات عن عدد الايام التي
يستطيع الانسان فيها ان يبقى على قيد
الحياه من دون ماء او غذاء
عند هذا الجزء المروع من السيناريو سيطل
فاصل سياسي قصير وقد يقال ان قليلا من
السياسه لن يزيد كميه الركام على اجساد
الناس المطمرين تحت انقاذ بيوتهم في شمال
غرب سوريا ولن يقلل كميه الاكسجين التي
نضبت لديهم او تكاد غير انه قد ينفع في
مساعده الباقين على قيد الحياه هناك ومن
يتعاطفون معهم على رؤيه ما يتوارى من
اجزاء الصوره وراء الركام وهي اجزاء ستظهر
فيها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي غزت
العراق واحتلت برغم انف الدول الكبرى
والصغرى في الامم المتحده قد صارت تتحجج
منذ سنين بالفيديو الروسي في مجلس الامن
الدولي لتمتنع ومعها بقيه الدول الغربيه
عن ادخال كيس من الاغذيه والادويه الى
شمال غرب سوريا الا بموافقه الكرملين اما
العرب او اكثريه انظمه حكمهم فما عاد
لديهم هم فيما يتعلق بالشان السوري سوى
تعويم الرئيس بشار الاسد حتى ولو على دم
ضحايا الزلزال في حين اصبحت الدول
الاقليميه الكبرى تتلاقى ايضا على الموقف
نفسه او لا تعترض عليه وان كان لكل منها
سببه مختلف تركيا تنكفئ على معالجات
نصيبها من الزلزال عشيه انتخاباتها
المرتقبه في ايار مايو المقبل وايران
تواصل التمسك بموقفها في نصره نظام الحكم
واسرائيل التي حظيت بجبهه هادئه في
الجولان طوال خمسه عقود من حكم ال الاسد
والمحكومه اليوم بيمين دينيا متطرف تعتبر
بلسان حاخاماتها ان ما حدث عقاب الهي
للمسلمين بعربهم واتراكهم على حد سواء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بالعوده الى سيناريو الاحداث ومع حلول
اليوم السادس لن يسيخ العالم سمعه لتساؤل
الوف السوريين عن عدد الخيانات الكبرى
التي يمكن للضمير الانساني ان يبقى بعدها
على قيد الحياه وفي السابع او الثامن او
التاسع ستطوى صفحه الموت السوري ويعود
ساده الكون ليستانفوا خطط ايصال مساعدات
عسكريه بمليارات الدولارات الى اوكرانيا
حتى تنتصر على الغزو الروسي وطبعا تحت
شعارات قيميه عنوانها الانتصار للحق في
مواجهه الباطل
ينضم الينا من واشنطن جاسم مارتس المسؤول
بقسم الشرق الاوسط بمنظمه ريفيوجيز
انترناشونال مرحبا بك سيد مارس
يعني ماذا يمكن
ان يقال عن هؤلاء المنكوبين في مناطق شمال
غرب سوريا الذين هم في الاصل نازحون
ولاجئون ايضا
والان هم منكوبون بالزلزال واكثر من ذلك
منعت المساعدات عنهم
واقفلت المعابر وغير ذلك ماذا يقال عن هذا
الواقع
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه اعتقد ان سته ايام
هي مده طويله نحن في اليوم السادس وسوريا
تعاني من كارثه بعد سنوات طويله من النزاع
هناك جهود
لانتشالي الجثث في المناطق السوريه هناك
فقط تغطيه لخمسه بالمئه من المناطق التي
تاثرت وامام الناجين هذا امر ماساوي
ونتحدث عن اكثر من 3000 من القتلى وسوف
ترتفع الايام او الاعداد مع الايام ان
الامم المتحده يجب ان تتصرف بشكل سريع لكي
تفتح كل المعابر لضمان المساعده للشعب
السوري ان غضب الناس يمكن ان يبرر بكل
المقاييس وانا اتعاطف معهم هناك مستويات ق
من الالم نتحدث عن اكثر من اربعه ملايين
شخص قبل الزلزال كانوا يعانون من مشاكل
ومن ازمات انسانيه متتاليه وقد تعاظمت
وتفاقمت هذه الازمات والناس لا يحصلون على
اي مساعدات وهذا يؤدي الى خطر على حياتهم
طيب ومن المسؤول عن ذلك برايك
هناك اماكن متعدده يمكن ان نلقي اللوم
باتجاهه لماذا لم تصل المساعدات لماذا ليس
هناك جهات مانحه اكثر لماذا لا تفتح
المعابر والحدود وتعبر الفرق الى سوريا
هناك جهات متعدده تؤدي ادوار من حيث
المسؤوليه ولكن السؤال بالنسبه الى او
المساله الاساسيه ليست بالقاء اللون بل
بتخطي هذه الازمات والمازق السياسيه
للتاكد من مساعدتي الناس ان مرحله التعافي
سوف تتطلب ايام واشهر ولذلك نحن بحاجه الى
العمل لكي يصل تصل المساعدات في الاسبوع
المقبل وحتى بعد سته اشهر يجب ان يحصل
الناس على المساعده لكي تتم مرحله التعافي
يجب ان نتاكد من ذلك عندما
يسال المسؤولون مسؤولون منظمات الدوليه
للمنظمات الاغاثيه وحتى صليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر وغيرهم عندما يسالون يقال
المساله معقده وتحتاج الى موافقات سياسيه
وغير ذلك هل بامكان هذه المنظمات ان تضغط
هل لديها قدره على الضغط من اجل
تجاوز تلك الحسابات السياسيه
لكل تاكيد منذ البدايه هناك نقاش على
مستوى مجلس الامن التابع للامم المتحده
منذ 8 سنوات انه وكلات الامم المتحده لم
تتمكن من الوصول الى الشمال غرب السوري
ومعبر باب الهوى بنفسه تضررت تركيا ايضا
قيل انها فتحت معبرين اخرين للسماح بمرور
المنظمات غير الحكوميه ولكن الامم المتحده
من غير مرجح ان تتمكن من العبور وان الدول
الاعضاء والجهات المانحه والمنظمات كلها
يجب ان تضغط على الامم المتحده من خلال
مجلس الامن لكي تفتح المعابر بشكل كامل
على سبيل المثال باب السلامه ومعبر موجود
على بعد كيلومترات قليله من مطار في تركيا
هناك طرق وسبل لوجستيه تسمح لنا بايصال
المساعدات الى سوريا
اذا
لم يشفع لسكان شمال غرب سوريا حجم محل بهم
من نتائج كارثيه للزلزال كهرمان مرش تاخرت
المساعدات ولم تحتوي على ما كانت تريده
فرق لانقاذ العامله هناك لاغاثه الضحايا
في الوقت المناسب
ورغم اعلان النظام السوري استعداده لادخال
المساعدات عبر مناطق باتجاه مناطق
المعارضه لان المناسق الاممي لشؤون
الانسانيه في سوريا قال ان هناك حاجه الى
موافقات اسئله كثيره يلف الغموض اجابتها
بشان تاخر ادخال المساعدات الى شمال غرب
سوريا في مثل هذه الظروف غير العاديه
بعد سته ايام على زلزال كهرمان مراش
المدمر تدخل قافله مساعدات اموميه مكونه
من 22 شاحنه عبر معبر باب الهواء الحدود
مع تركيا
حمولتها مساعدات طبيه وخيام وهي اول قافله
مخصصه لمواجهه اثار الزلزال تدخل الى شمال
غرب سوريا الدفاع المدني اتهم صراحه للامم
المتحده والمجتمع الدوليه بالتخاذل عن مد
يد العون فالمساعدات تاخرت وخلت من
المعدات الثقيله للعمليات الاكثر الحاحا
اي انقاذ الارواح
حتى مع هذا الظرف الاستثنائي لا يبدو
ادخال المساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا سهلا
فمن المقرر عقد جلسه لمجلس الامن لبحث فتح
معابر جديده لادخال المساعدات الامميه
فما هي طرق ادخال المساعدات الى شمال غرب
سوريا مناطق المعارضه المحاذيه لتركيا
لديها معبران رئيسيان هما باب الهواء في
ريفي ادلب ومنه دخلت المساعدات الاخيره
والاخر هو باب السلامه في ريف حلب وهو
مغلق منذ سنوات لعدم تجديد توفيد الاموي
لدخول المساعدات منه كما توجد معابر اخرى
يطلق عليها المعابر المدنيه التجاريه وهي
معبر جرابلس والراعي والحمام
وتجهيزها اقل من معبر باب الهوى وباب
السلامه وسمح تركيا باستخدامها لادخال
المساعدات الانسانيه المقدمه من المنظمات
المحليه او من دوله بعينها الطريقه
الثانيه هي ما يطلق عليه ادخال المساعدات
عبر خطوط الناس اي ان تدخل المساعدات
الامميه الى مناطق السيطره النظام ثم تنقل
الى مناطق المعارضه النظام السوري كان
وافق على ايصال المساعدات حتى الى المناطق
الخارجه عن السيطره لكن المنسقه الامميه
للشؤون الانسانيه في سوريا قال ان المنظمه
بحاجه الى موافقات لدخول مناطق شمال غرب
سوريا وانه لم يسمح بادخال اي مساعدات من
مناطق التماس بين النظام والمعارضه لم
يحدد المسؤول الاممي الجهه التي منعت دخول
المساعدات ولا تلك التي لا بد من اذنها
الثابت ان شده زلزال وكارثيه نتائجى لم
تنجي السوريين من الحسابات السياسيه في
ظرف دولي معقد
معنا من بيروت الدكتور حسام الشرقاوي
المدير الاقليمي للاتحاد الدولي لجمعيات
الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر في شمال
افريقيا والشرق الاوسط دكتور حسام
هل اقنعتك كل المبررات التي
تقدم لحجب المساعدات عن شمال غرب سوريا
اشكرك انا لن ادخل في الامور السياسيه
تركيزنا على الانساني ونعامل جميع
السوريين
لتاثروا بالزلزال
على نفس المستوى
الوضع الامني في بعض المناطق حساس جدا
والكل يعلم ذلك ما في داعي لتفسيس الامور
اكثر من هكذا هذه نتيجه 12 سنه حرب وعدم
وجه وجود حل سياسي
كمنظمات انسانيه نتعامل بنتائج عدم وجود
حل سياسي اللي اظهرها الان الزلزال وهذه
الكارثه انا هذه الجلديه
نعم قلت الاسبوع الماضي ماذا
انا كنت في سوريا الاسبوع الماضي بعد
الزلزال
في مفاوضات حساسه لايصال الدعم لجميع
المناطق وان شاء الله هيوصل
لجميع المناطق اللي تاثر فيها الشعب
السوري
يعني حتى الان لم تصل هذه المساعدات هناك
مفاوضات تجري مع من تجري هذه المفاوضات من
يقود هذه المفاوضات
لا استطيع التكلم عن هذه هذه امور حساسه
جدا
وبعض الدعم وصل من خلال هلال الاحمر
العربي السوري وفروعه والمتطوعين
المتطوعات اللي هم كانوا المستجيب الاول
في كثير مناطق يتواجدون فيها هم اهل البلد
هم ليس غرباء هذه البلد دورنا ندعمهم
ونقويهم لرسال الانسانيه وهذا ما نفعله
الان هدول اشخاص
يعملون برساله انسانيه بعيدا عن السياسه
ولا اريد تسييس عملهم ابدا لانه هذا قد
يؤذي الجميع
موجودون انتم الان الان هل هل تعملون
كمنظمه دوليه في شمال غرب سوريا
المناطق اللي يمكن الوصول الها بامن
الهلال الاحمر السوري موجود فيها مثل وين
في اماكن صعب
الوصول لها في اماكن يوصلها الهلال الاحمر
التركي من سنوات
عبر المعابر اللي تفضلتوا فيها في تقريركم
في مناطق خارج شمال غرب سوريا في حلب
وطرطوس ونتايه برضه تاثرت في الزلزال
والان يصلها الدعم فلا نفرق
الفئات حسب الحدود وحسب الخطوط ولكن نريد
ان نفهم الجغرافيا يعني الان اين يعمل
الهلال الاحمر
تحديدا اين يعمل في اي مناطق من شمال غرب
سوريا قلت المناطق التي يمكن الوصول اليها
ما هي المناطق التي يمكن الوصول اليها او
امكنكم الوصول اليها
كثير من الارياف والقرى التي يتواجد فيها
الفروع في
مناقشات
لاعاده فتح الفرع في ادلب للهلال الاحمر
العربي السوري وهذا مهم جدا
وقد يساعد في ايصال المساعدات بطريقه اسرع
واقوى والمناطق الاخرى احنا
اعلنت في الولايات المتحده اول امس عن رفع
العقوبات على التحويلات الماليه لمده
تنميه يوم وهذا الشيء بنرحب فيه ونشكرهم
لانه هذا حيساعد برضو انه نوسع رقعه
الجغرافيه
والكم من العمل الانساني في مناطق ريف
اعزاز مثلا مناطق ريف اعزاز في ريف ادلب
تعملون يعني هناك شكوى من من هناك
مستمره من عدم وجود منظمات دوليه واغاسات
ودعم ومساعدات
اكيد
الناس
ليس جميع المناطق وصلها الدعم في كارثه من
حجم هذا انا عملت في اكثر من 35 سنه في
مجال العمل الانساني وبالذات الزلازل في
عده الدول صعب جدا انه خلال خمس او ست
ايام يوصل الدعم للجميع احنا نتفهم جميعا
انه لكثير من العائلات هي قصه حياه او موت
وهذا مؤلم جدا
فاللي انا شفته بعيني نعم خليه من النحل
تعمل 24 ساعه لايصال المساعدات
اللي لاي مكان في سوريا ممكن توصل
المساعدات بشكل امن وهذا مهم جدا للطواقل
يعني عفوا دكتور حسام يبقى السؤال متعلق
بتلك المناطق شمال غرب سوريا والتي لم تكن
هناك اجابه واضحه بانه ستصل
المساعدات يعني حتى الان ليس هناك اي
مسؤول لا اممي ولا حتى من منظمات انسانيه
واغاثيه يؤكد ان المساعدات ستصل الى تلك
المناطق
انا اليوم كنت في اجتماع مع الهلال الاحمر
العربي السوري وفي قافله تجهز غدا للتوجه
الى ادلب ان شاء الله توصل وان شاء الله
تكون بارده خير وبعدها توصل مئات القوافل
لهذه المناطق اخذتم موافقات للحصول اليها
اخذتم موافقات
اكيد اكيد كل الموافقات
والقافله تجهز طب ليش لبكره
الهلال الاحمر العربي السوري هو المخول ان
اتكلم عن هذا وارجو ان تعملوا لقاء معهم
مباشره تسمعوا منه مباشره
وهم يشاركوا ما هي الرساله الانسانيه الحل
للازمه بسوريا ليس حال عمل انساني او
مؤسسات انسانيه هو حال دبلوماسي وسياسي
شكرا نحن نتعامل مع مع
التاثير غياب الحل الدبلوماسي والسياسي
ونحث الدول ان تاخذ دورها
والدبلوماسيين ان يقوموا لايجاد جزيلا
دكتور حسام الشرقاوي المدير الاقليمي
للاتحاد الدولي للجمعيات الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر في شمال افريقيا والشرق
الاوسط حدثنا من بيروت
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيه تداعيات
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا سنعود
للمتابعه مجددا بعد وقفه قصيره مع اخبار
اخرى
قالت الاداره الاقليميه الاوكرانيه في
دينيبرو شرقيه البلاد ان مسيرات روسيه هجم
ثلاث منشات للطاقه في منطقتي كريدي
وذاكرت الاداره الاقليميه ان منشاه في
منطقه كريفي هجمت مرتين في يوم واحد ما
اسفر عندما رن كبير
اكدنا ابو وزير الخارجيه
الروسيلين ان موسكو ستكون مستعده للتفاوض
مع كييف ولكن دون شروط مسبقه وعلى اساس
الواقع القائم واوضح ان القرار بشان
المفاوضات في يد بروكسل واشنطن وليس لدى
كييف
اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بلده
عناته في مدينه القدس فجر اليوم تاتي
الاقتحامات في اطار التصعيد الذي تقوم به
قوه الاحتلال في البلدات القديمه
افدى فلسطينيون يقتنون في ضاحيه جبل مكبر
في القدس المحتله ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي سلمتهم اخطارات بهدم منازلهم
خلال الايام المقبله ما سيؤدي الى تشريد
نحو 120 مواطنا واكدوا ان قوه حرس الحدود
سلمتهم الاختارات اليوم بذريعه ان منازلهم
لم تحصل على تراخيص من السلطات يذكر ان
وزيرا امن القومي الاسرائيلي اعلن عن خطه
لمضاعفه عدد منازل الفلسطينيين غير
الشرعيه حسب تعبيره والتي سياشرع في هدمها
انها ثانيه عشره منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه هذا تذكير بابرز العناوين
بعد سته ايام على وقوع الكارثه حصيله ضحيه
زلزالك كهرمان مراش في تركيا وسوريا تقارب
26 الفا الامم المتحده تصف الكارثه
بالاسوا في المنطقه منذ مئه عام ومارتن
جريفيث يقول ان مرحله الانقاذ تقترب من
نهايتها وتقارير عن تسجيل نحو 70 هزه
ارتداديه على امتداد اليوم
تفاقم القلق
مع دخول عمليات الانقاذ مرحله حاسمه فرق
الانقاذ تنجح في اخراج ناجين من تحت
الانقاض في مدن تركيا تحقيقات واعتقالات
في مناطق متضرره على خلفيه اتهامات بغش في
البناء والسلطات تقول ان ترحيل المنكوبين
اهم الاولويات اردوغان يعيد باستكمال
اعاده الاعمار في غضون عام
وفي شمال سوريا انتقادات تتزايد للتاخير
الدولي في ارسال المساعدات ومع اول قافله
دعم امميه تدخل الى سوريا بعد سته ايام
على الكارثه مطالب بعدم تسييس المساعدات
ومناسق الامم المتحده لشؤون الانسانيه في
سوريا يقترح عبر الجزيره تجاوز صعوبات
بادخال المساعدات الى سوريا عبر معادر
اخرى مع تركيا
[موسيقى]
ومباشره ننتقل الى تصريحات لنائب الرئيس
التركي فؤاد اقطعي
مروحيه
تم طبعا ارسالهم الى المنطقه
وايضا
المسيرات التركيه ايضا
اتت الى المنطقه لتضبيط جراح المنكوبين
عمليه البحث والانقاذ
مستمره ولن نفقد الامل حتى اخر لحظه
طبعا نحن
ننجز عمليه رفع الانقاذ باقرب وقت
طبعا
سندفن جميع
الموتى طبعا في اقرب وقت ممكن مع مراعاه
طبعا مثل ما قلنا كل التفاصيل القانونيه
الدينيه
ولذلك
المدعين
العامين ايضا يعملون على
تثبيت هويات الاشخاص
وتسجيل طبعا الوفيات بشكل قانوني
طبعا وفقا لما يقومون باعمال
ورصد
للواقع
طبعا
هناك
طبعا تاسيس
لقسم خاص تمام
تاسيسه بخصوص التحقيق
بالجرائم المتعلقه بالزلزال حتى الان
تمام
القبض على العديد من
اشخاص
في هذا طبعا
في هذا السياق
والاشخاص الذين بنوا
مباني
ضررا بالارواح كلهم
سيحاكمون
والقانون
سيقاضيهم
ايضا
هناك اشكاليات متعلقه بالصحه
وخوف من انتشار او
لذلك
يتم اتخاذ
التدابير والاجراءات الوقائيه
يتم اتخاذ كل هذه كل التدابير لمنع حدوث
اي من
الاوبئه المتعلقه طبعا
بالاماكن المنكوبه
ايضا بالنسبه
التدفئه تم التوزيع
المدفات العامله على الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
هدفنا هو ان نوفر
للمنكوبين طبعا
دافئا في هذه الظروف الصعبه
من الصين حتى باكستان طبعا
نعرف ولدينا خبره في مجال الاسعافات
الاوليه
[موسيقى]
طبعا
سيتم استخدام المروحيات
في ايصال الخيم للمناطق النائيه
تركيا طبعا كدوله اصلا
منفتحه
وعلى الخارج طبعا
تلقينا دعما خارجيا
طبعا داخليا نحن متضامنين مع الشعب مع
شعبنا
وايضا اكملنا هذا التضامن مع الدعم الدولي
الذي وصلنا واشكر جميع من السعاده وساهم
في عمليه الانقاذ
هناك رحلات
مجانيه تم توفيرها بهذا القدر
لتصريحات فؤي نائب الرئيس التركي وهو
يتحدث عما انجز وما يتم انجازه وما تعتزم
السلطات واجهزه الانقاذ والبحث القيامه به
لاحقا لمتابعه ما يحصل في هذه الاثناء من
عمليات بحث
وانقاذ وكيف تبدو الاوضاع كان في تركيا او
حتى في سوريا شمال غرب سوريا ينضم الينا
من غازي عنتاب مراسل الجزيره منتصر ابو
نبوت ومن اعزاز في ريف حلب مراسل الجزيره
محمد الجزائري ونبدا باك
منتصر يعني كما هو واضح المكان الذي
تتواجد فيه مكان
مبنيه مهدمه عمليات الانقاذ المستمره لكن
وكانه اطفئت الانوار من خلفك الان ماذا
يجب
حسن في الحقيقه هذا المكان تقريبا انتهت
به عمليه البحث عن ضحايا تقريبا جميع
الضحايا خرجوا بحسب مبلغونا قبل قليل هذا
مبنى من عده مباني يعني
دمرت في هذا الحي لكنهم الان يقومون
بعمليه
يعني البحث الاخير وايضا بازاله الركام
الان تاتي بعض السيارات ويتم ازاله الركام
من هذا المكان بعد ان قاموا بانتشال جميع
الضحايا وخرج من خرج من اشخاص على قيد
الحياه من هذا المبنى بالطبع محمد بطبع
حسن هذا هذا الامر في في مدينه غازي عنتاب
لا يتعلق فقط بمركز المدينه او نحن نتحدث
عن مناطق اخرى في غازي عنتاب تعرضت لدمار
كبير ودمار واسع كنا قد تحدثنا عن مدينه
الاصلاحيه التي تتبع اداريا لمدينه غازي
عنتاب او لولايه غازي عنتاب وقد دمر اجزاء
كبيره منها اكثر من نصف هذه المدينه هو
اما مدمر او يعني قايل للسقوط او تعرض
الاداره الكبير وذلك بحسب ما صرحت به رئيس
رئيسه بلديه غازي عنتاب فاطمه شاهين ايضا
مدينه نورداغ القريبه ايضا من الاصلاحيه
وهي تتبع اداريا لغازي عنتاب لما دخلناها
اليوم كان فيها ايضا عدد ابنيه مدمره بشكل
هائل والاتصالات مقطوعه في تلك المنطقه
حتى هذه اللحظه يعني هنالك بعض
الاطراف هذه المدينه يمكن ان نحصل فيها
على اتصالات لكن داخل هذه المدينه لا يوجد
فيها اتصالات لان ابراج اتصالات قد دمرت
والدمار واسع في تلك المدينه بين هاتين
المدينتين يعني هنالك رابط مشترك وهو
الخيام التي نصبت في كل من المدينه خيام
كثيره وكان وزير الاسكان تحدث من من بلده
او من مدينه الاصلاحيه يوم امس عندما جاء
مع فاطمه شاهين الى تلك المدينه وقال ان
هناك خمسه عشر الف خيمه نصبت في ولايه
غازي عنتاب وحده وان هذا على سيرتفع الى
25 الف خيمه الحقيقه الاوضاع تزداد سوءا
خصوصا مع تدني درجات الحراره وايضا وجود
اشخاص كثيرين في الشوارع وفي الساحات
العامه بيوتهم غير مدمره لذلك الحكومه
التركيه تعطي الاولويه للاشخاص المنكوبين
الذين دمرت منازلهم لكن هؤلاء الاشخاص
بيوتهم غير مدمره لكنهم خائفون مدعورون من
العوده الى منازلهم بعد حادثه الزلزال
والجميع يعني يرتقب ويراقب الى اين سيؤول
هذا الامر خصوصا مع استمرار الهزات
الارتداديه واستمرار
الابنيه التي تهدم يعني صباح اليوم سقط
بناء في
مدينه غازي عنتاب وكان هذا البناء ايضا
للسقوط بسبب
السابقه وفعلا عندما يعني
كان كان الفجر اليوم
سقط هذا البناء لم يتضرر احد لان كان قد
اخليه من السكان في وقت سابق ابقى معنا
منتصر لننتقل الى اعزاز في حلب مع محمد
الجزائري
ورصد للاوضاع هناك
وعمليات الايواء انت تحدثنا من من امام
مجموعه من الخيم
المخصصه لواء المنكوبين محمد
نعم حسن في حقيقه هذه الخيام هي خيام
ايواء مؤقته للمتضرين من جراء هذا الزلزال
والذين فقدوا منازلهم او تصدعت منازلهم
ولم تعد صالحه للسكن ومنازل منها دمر
جزئيا فيلجاون الى هذه النقاط المؤقته
للاقامه يلجاون اليها يقيمون فيها الى ان
يتبين لديهم الى اين سيكون مصيرهم الى
المخيمات او الى منازل اخرى
تتبع لاقاربهم او يذهبون الى
اقاربهم ومنازل اخرى حقيقه هذه النقاط
الايواء المؤقته رغم ما تستقبلهم من اعداد
كبيره من الاهالي ولكن هي رغم ذلك قليله
وشهيها وتعاني من قله المساعدات الانسانيه
من قبل مساعدات المقدمه من قبل المنظمات
المحليه لهؤلاء الاهالي فهو المنظمات
المحليه لا تقدم الى بعض الوجبات الغذائيه
والاغطيه
والمساعدات من سلا الغذائيه وغيرها ولكن
الاهالي يح بحسب ما سمعنا منهم وجلسنا
معهم يحتاجون اقل ما يمكن الى خيام يقيمون
بها كل عائله وحدها يقيمون في هذه الخيام
كل عائله لوحدها وليس الخيام القيم كما
نشاهد هذه القيام التي خلفي يقيم فيها
النساء والاطفال بينما الشباب يجلسون خارج
الخيام في النهار يذهبون الى اعمالهم وفي
الليل يجلسون خارج هذه القيام حتى او
يتدافؤون على بعض اشعال الاطارات وغيرها
حقيقه هذه الماساه هنا في هذه النقاط
قائمه المؤقته للاهالي ولكن الماساه
الكبرى او الاكبر هي في مناطق التي تعرضت
للدمار الكبير
والمناطق التي اعلنت من كوبا بشكل كبير
والمناطق التي تضررت جراء هذا الزلزال
كمادي دمر فيها عدد كبير من الابنيه وبحسب
الاحصائيات المحليه فهناك اكثر من 80% من
مدينه جنديرس مدمر بالكامل او بشكل جزئي
او متصدع لا يصلح للسكن ومع اعلان فراق
الدفاع المدني او الدفاع المدني انتهاء
عمليه البحث والانقاذ الى وانتقال الى
عمليات البحث والانتشال بات الواقع صعب
جدا فهذه الفرق الدفاع المدنيه
بامكانياتها المحدوده تختلف الواقع هنا عن
ما يحصل في تركيا في الفرق في في تركيا
تمتلك تجهيزات ومعدات وتقنيات عاليه بينهم
فرق الدفاع المدني هنا في الداخل السوري
لا تمتلك الا بضع الاليات الثقيله
والاليات الخفيفه بينما لا تمتلك تحتاج
بشكل كبير كانت تحتاج الى اجهزه السماع
واجهزه السماع الاصوات تحت الانقراض
بالاضافه الى الكاميرات الحراريه لمعرفه
الاشخاص اينما التواجدون وانقاذهم ولكن مع
المضوي خمسه ايام ونحن ندخل الى اليوم
السادس بات الواقع صعب جدا لذلك اتخذ
الدفاع المدني القرار بانتقال الى هذه
المرحله
البحث والانتشال لان فرق الدفاع المدني
تعمل وحدها دون اي مساعده او دون اي
مؤازره من فرق دوليه او فرق للدفاع المدني
او ف وانقاذ ان كان بالامكانيات او
الخبرات او حتى الاليات محمد الجزائري من
اعزاز في حلب شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا لمنتصر
ابو نبوت كان معنا من غازي عنتاب
[موسيقى]
كيف لا يحتفى بالحياه هي هنا حياه عائشه
الفتاه التركيه الخارجه الينا من تحت
الانقاذ
مثلها كتبت النجاه لذاك الطفل الرضيع
[موسيقى]
ولان في العمر بقيه تخرج الى النور سيده
سبعينيه حصرت بين انقاض مبنى من طوابق عده
[موسيقى]
الساعات الطوال الثقال على المنقذين
ومنقذيهم قد تفضي اذا الى ما يهون المصاب
وفي وقائعك هذه حتما ما يبث املا في نفوس
من لا زالوا ينتظرون عوده قريب مفقود
واضح ان الامل القائم في مركز الزلزال
الاسوء في المنطقه منذ قرن تعززه امكانات
البحث والانقاذ التركيه والدعم القادم
اليها من الخارج
[تصفيق]
ليت الامر كذلك وراء الحدود الجنوبيه
يعلم السوريون في المناطق المنكوبه
بالزلزال ان ليس لهم غير الله كما قالوا
ادومه من سيلومون على جعل معدات الانقاذ
والاسعاف الحيويه حلما بعيدا المنال
لم نتلقى اي شيء عبر الحدود الى حد اللحظه
لا فرق انقاذ ولا تجهيزات طبيه ولا غذاء
بعد خمسه ايام من الزلزال اننا نحتاج الى
اغاثه غذائيه وعلاجيه وايواء عاجلا غير
اجل
لا ينشغل الناس هنا في الشمال السوري
المنكوب بالمسؤوليات التي تتقاذفها
الاطراف عن التقصير والتاخير
يبقيهم هنا الامل في ان ثمه انفاسا تحت
هذا الركام لم تنقطع
لكن العجز يتملكهم بعد الانتقال الى
عمليات البحث والانتشال فالخوض البيض تخرج
من الجثث اكثر مما تعثره على ناجين يمضي
الوقت ومعه تفرض الحكمه تحويل الاهتمام
كله نحو الناجين ممن شردهم الزلزال
[موسيقى]
اولئك بحاجه الى ايواء واعاشه وذاك وعد
اخر اخلفه كما يبدو جل الواعدين
السعي مستمرون اذا للوصول الى ناجين ومنذ
وقوع الكارثه تنقسم جهود الاستجابه لها
الى ثلاث مراحل رئيسيه تبدا بمحاوله
الوصول الى العليقين باسرع وقت ممكن
وتنتهي بازاله اثار الركام والانقراض
للتعرف اكثر على تفاصيل تلك المراحل نتابع
التقدير التالي
بعد لحظات الزلزال العصيبه تتركز الجهود
في المرحله الاولى للاستجابه للكارثه على
البحث عن الناجين وانقاذ العدد الاكبر من
الارواح يستعان في ذلك بمجموعه من المعدات
تعجل بالوصول لاماكن العالقين تحت الانقاض
وفجوات الركام مثل نظام دار القادر على
رصد الاجسام الثابته والمتحركه عبر
الخرسانه المسلحه ومعدات الصوت الحساسه
والكاميرات الحراريه وايضا الكلاب المدربه
تستمر هذه المرحله ما بين خمسه الى سبعه
ايام
ارتضائلوا فرص العثور على احياء بعد ذلك
لكن استمرار البحث عن المتبقي من الناجين
واستمرارا انتشال جثامين الضحايا ودفنهم
قد يستمر لايام اطول ثم تاتي مرحله
الاغاثه الطارئه تتوجه الجهود هنا نحو
تقديم المساعده العاجله لمن شردتهم كارثه
وتشمل تامين الماوى المؤقت وتوفير الماء
والغذاء اضافه الى رعايه الطبيه
والاسعافات الاوليه مده هذه المرحله تطول
او تقصر بحسب حجم المناطق المتضرره من
الزلزال والامكانات المتاحه لفرق الاغاثه
بعد ذلك ينتقل الى المرحله الاخيره مرحله
التعافي التي تبدا بايجاد ماوى للعائلات
المنكوبه يكون قادرا على تحمل الظروف
الجويه كالامطار والرياح مع توفر امكانيه
الوصول للمياه والغذاء ليتم الانتقال بعد
ذلك الى فحص المباني المتضرره وازاله
الخطر منها ثم العمل على ازاله الركام
والانقاض والبدء باصلاح شبكات الصرف الصحي
والمياهي والكهرباء وقد تستمر هذه المرحله
سنوات للتخلص من كافه اثار الزلزال
[موسيقى]
معنى من الصندوق محمد فاروق اوز تورك
مسؤول الامن الغذائي في هيئه الاغاثه
الانسانيه محمد مرحبا بك يعني
التركيز بشكل اساسي في المراحل الاولى
طبعا يكون على عمليات
محاوله انقاذ منهم على قيد الحياه سحب جثث
سحب جرحى رفع انقاض لكن مساله الامن
الغذائي ايضا لهؤلاء المنكوبين الذين
خرجوا من بيوتهم بلا شيء هي مساله ايضا
مهمه وملحه كيف تجري عمليات الاغاثه
غذائيا للمنكوبين
نعم العمليات الاغاثيه حتى اليوم وزعنا
وجبه ساخنه حوالي خمسه مئه الف شخص ومع
ذلك وزرنا خمسه مئه الف خبز واليوم بدانا
في مشروع الحي الكونتينر لكي يعيش
المتضررين من الزلزال حتى يتم بناء بيوتهم
الجديده ومع ذلك ما زلنا
نستمر في توزيع السلل الغذائيه وجبه
الساخنه وبطانيات والسرير
هل هذه
يعني حملات الاغاثه هذه مستمره موضوع
الامن الغذائي يعني يفترض ان يكون مستمر
وايام وربما لاسابيع الى حين يتدبر هؤلاء
المنكوبون اوضاعهم
نعم هذا هو النقطه المهمه اللي هو الامن
الغذائي لا يكون المساعده
يعني واحده ان يكون مستمره والا لن يكون
هناك اي امن غذائي
طيب
كيف يمكنكم تغطيه هذه الرقعه الواسعه من
المناطق المنكوبه
كيف يمكن ما هي الاليات المتبعه من اجل
تغطيه هذه الرقعه الواسعه من المناطق
المدمره والتي يوجد فيها منكوبون
يحتاجون الى غذاء
نعم بعدما يتم البحث والانقاذ
سنبدا في هذه المشروع في حي الكونتينر
بعدين هذه
مساعده الاغاثه خاصه في سله الغذائيه
سيكون في ستاندر
في شروط الانترنيشن حتى يكون ان الغذائي
هل نفهم اكثر منك ما هو حي الكونتينر
نعم الحيه الكونتينر هو اربعين مربع حتى
يعيش عائله كامله فيه مطبخ وحمام
نعم صحيح
تنتظرون ان
تتم
بناء هذه الاحياء من اجل ان ينتظم عملكم
اكثر او يتوقف عملكم حينئذ
لا حتى حتى لا يتوقف كما كما تعرفون رئيس
الجمهور اخطر ان البيوت سيتم بناؤهم خلال
سنه
للمتضررين من الزلزال وحتى هذا الوقت
هذه العوايل سيعيش في هذه الكونتينرات من
اسطنبول محمد فاروق نعم محمد فاروق مسؤول
الامن الغذائي في هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك
هول الغياب تحت الارض والمعارك مع الامل
في الخروج على قيد الحياه قصص لنجينا من
الزلزال في اديمان التركيه قابلتهم مراسله
الجزيره سلام خضر واعدت تقرير التالي
الامل عما بقي حيا فوق الارض
ليتمسك من هو عالق تحتها بخيط حياه الرفيع
ايام تمر وناجون ينهضون من تحت الابنيه
المنهاره هنا يشيرون اليها بالمعجزات
يرشدنا فرحات الى مبنى انهار على ساكنين
وهو كان منهم بقي عالقا تحت الركام نحو
ثلاثه عشره ساعه ساعه مروعه كان يسمع
خلالها اصوات اقاربه
بقيت تحت الانقاض استغيث ولم يسمعني احد
رغم انني كنت اسمع الضجيج في الخارج اللهم
نحني القوه للصمود وان اخرج حيا انها
معجزه وفقدت تحت الانقاض شقيقي وشقيقتي في
موقع قريب يحاول الرجال الانقاذ سحب شخص
من تحت الانقاض لا نعرف ان كان على قيد
الحياه
قصص ملهمه شهدنا عليها في زلزال كهرمان
مراش دفعتنا الى التساؤل ما الذي يساعد
الانسان على البقاء على قيد الحياه وسط
مشهد الدمار الكبير هذا وانعدام فرص
الحياه تحت الانقاض واستمرار الهزات
الارتداديه والبرد الشديد حملنا السؤال
الى فريق انقاذ مختص بالتعامل مع العالقين
الاحياء تحت الانقاض حجم المكان حيث يوجد
الشخص الناجي وشده الاصابه من العوامل
التي تلعب دورا في الصمود تحت الانقاض
ليبقى الجفاف هو التهديد الاخطر
محظوظين لاننا في الشتاء والطقس بارد وهذا
ما يبقي الاشخاص على قيد الحياه لمده اطول
بخلاف البلدان الاستوائيه والحاره حيث
يصعب البقاء على قيد الحياه لاكثر من
ثلاثه ايام مشاهد جويه تظهر جزءا من حجم
الدمار العظيم الذي لحق بادي يمان
التقديرات الاوليه تش الانهيار اكثر من
2650 مبنى في المدينه
ومئات اخرى ايله للسقوط اما عدد الضحايا
فلا يزال قيد الارتفاع سلام خضر الجزيره
اليمن
نحو اسبوع مر على حدوث زلزالك كهرمان مراش
المدمر ومع ذلك فان الهزات الارتداديه
لهذا الزلزال لا تزال مستمره
اكثر من الفيه هزاع سجلتها اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه حتى هذا اليوم والذي
اعلن فيه المركز الاورو المتوسطى لرصد
الزلازل تسجيل سبعين هزه ارضيه في تركيا
يتراوحت شدتها بين ثلاث واربع فاصل سبع
درجات على مقياس
ما هي هذه الهزات وما مدى خطورتها
وامني الاجابه عن هذه الاسئله في التقرير
التالي
بعد انتهاء زلزال كهرمان مارش يوم السادس
من فبراير شباط وحتى الوقت الحالي لم
تتوقف في الهزاف والخزاديه في معظم
المناطق التي ضربها سواء في تركيا او في
سوريا
استنادا لاداره الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
فان اكثر من الفيزه ارتداديه سجلت منذ
وقوع زلزال فما هي هذه الهزات الارتداديه
وما سببها وما مدى خطورتها يطلق على
الهزات الارتداديه توابع الزلزال او
الزلازل الصغيره اللاحقه وهي تحدث وفق
تفسير علماء من هيئه المسح الجيولوجيه
الامريكيه نتيجه محاوله الصفائح التكتونيه
للارض العوده الى مكانها على طول خط الصدع
بعد حدوث الزلزال الاشد هذه الهزات
الارتداديه او توابع الزلزال قد تستمر
اياما واسابيع وحتى سنوات من تاريخ حدود
الزلزال الاول للاشد وفق العلماء فان شده
تلك الهزات تتفاوت مع مرور الوقت فتكون
قويه خلال 48 ساعه الاولى بعد الزلزال
الاول لكنها تحدث دائما بدرجات اقل منه ثم
انخفاض شدتها بدرجات متفاوته لكن هل يعني
انخفاض وقله درجه الهزات الارتداديه ان
الخطر قد سال وفق تحرير كثير من هيئات
المسح الجيولوجيه في العالم فان خطوره هذه
الهزات الارتداديه تكمن في انها قد تسبب
انهيار ما خلخله وصدعه زلزال الاول من
مباني صمدت ولم تنهر كليا لذا يجب وفق
العلماء عدم المغامره بالرجوع الى اي مبنى
الا بعد تقييم حالته من المختصين
من بيروت معنا عبد الحج شحاده الخبير في
شؤون الجيولوجيا والزلازل السيد عبد مرحبا
بك
هل يفترض للهزات الارضيه
الارتداديه ان تقلق اكثر او ان تطمئن
بدايه بدي اتوجه
للشعب السوري والتركي واتمنى الرحمه
للضحايا اللي سقطوا
وشفاء العاجل للمصابين
لجاوبك على سؤالك الهزات الارتداديه هي
شيء طبيعي بصير بعد اي زلزال كبير
عاده تجي على فترات بتتراوح من بعد حصول
الزلزال ومعقول تمتد لاشهر وسنين بقل بقل
عددها وقوتها مع الوقت
وبتيجي عاده اخف من الزلزال الاساسي
بدرجتين او اكثر يعني بتيجي اذا مثلا
زلزال سبعه بدها تيجي درجتين اقل من
السبعه ونزول
هيدي الزلازل هي شيء طبيعي من سياق
الحدث الزلزال الاساسي وبيتبعوا هذا الحدث
الزلزال الاساسي
[موسيقى]
لماذا تحصل الهزه الارتداديه ماذا ماذا
تريد يعني
ماذا يحصل تحت الارض
يفسر لنا الهزه الارتداديه طيب الهزه
الكبرى او الزلزال بات مفهوما لماذا تحصل
الهزات
الارتداديه بشكل كبير
لانه هذا الفعل اللي تحرك
ما حيتحرك بشكل متكامل بحدث واحد اكيد
الجزء الاكبر من التحرك بصير يدق خلال
الهزه الكبيره يلي هي كانت سبعه فاصله
سبعه ولحقها سبعه فاصله خمسه على فالق
موازي لاله
بتصير بعدين لانه هذا الفيلم عم يجرب يرجع
يرجع
لشكله الاساسي يعني يبطل يبطل يعمل ريليس
او يطلق الطاقه اللي جواته
وبيرجع
طيب من بعد الزلزال الكبير وفي ضوء
استمرار الزلازل الارتداديه بدنا نسمع
تكهنات
حتى من خبراء جيولوجيين انه
يمكن ان يحصل زلزال كبير في المنطقه
الفلانيه او في البلد الفلاني او هذا
البلد الذي شعر بالزلزال الكبير هو على
فالق فبالتالي سيتحرك هذا الفالق لان
الارض اهتزت في هذا البلد نتيجه زلزال
كهرمان مراشي واصبحت الناس خائفه في اكثر
من بلد ما مدى واقعيه وعلميه ما يقال في
هذا الشهر
بدايه
[موسيقى]
انا صراحه كاختصاصي بجيولوجيا عم بتفرج
على اللي عم بيصير صرت عطلان هم العالم
قديش عم بتخاف اكثر من معتلان هم الزلزال
يعني العالم عم بيصير عندها حالات من
الهلا نتيجه الاشاعه اللي عم تنتشر بها
الوسائل تواصل اجتماعي بالاخص يلي هي انا
كنت بعتقد انه هدفها تواعي وتريح العالم
صارت مصدر قلق للعالم
بالنسبه للتوقع توقع الزلازل توقع الزلازل
مثل ما اجمعوا جميع الخبراء بهالمجال انه
هذا الشيء بعد لا يزال مستحيل ما فينا
نتنبا ايمتن حيصير زلزال فينا نتوقع الخطر
الزلزالي بمنطقه معينه واكيد بدقه مش كتير
مش كتير عاليه يعني بنعرف انه مثلا نحن
كوننا ناخذ مثلا لبنان نحن عايشين بلبنان
على على خطوط زلزاليه نعرف انه هالخطوط
الزلزاليه بتعمل زلازل وبتعمل زلازل بين
800 لل 1200 سنه وق سبعه بس مش معناتها
حتصير هلا ما حدا بيقدر يتكهن ايمتى رح
يصير زلزل
فتنبؤات اللي عم بتصير يعني ما بعرف شو
مصدرها او باي اطار عم بتصير بس علميا
جميع مجمع انه تنبؤ الزلزال ايمتى رح
يصيروا باي لحظه بعده مستحيل شكرا لك عبد
الحاج
الخبير في شؤون الجيولوجيا والزلازل من
بيروت
في سوريا تراجعت الامل بالعثور على مزيد
من الناجين تحت انقاذ بيوتهم في مناطق
شمال غرب البلاد بعد سته ايام اعقبت
الزلزله المدمر واتسمت بشحن يقترب من
العدم في المساعدات الاقليميه والدوليه
كان متحدثون باسم منظمات انسانيه محليه
وعالميه قد طلبوا دون جدوى بتزويد فرق
الانقاذ في الشمال السوري بالادوات
والوسائل والمعدات الضروريه لعمليات البحث
عن الناجين وانتشال الضحايا من تحت الركام
تقرير ماجد عبد الهادي
يا الله اني اتهم جمله قصيره يستلها
السوريون الان من روايات الظلم في التاريخ
الانساني ليكتبوها ومعها عبارات اخرى
ترادفها معنى على صفحات ماساتهم او
ليرددوها باصواتهم المخنوقه تحت وفوق ركام
بيوتهم التي دمرها الزلزال وقد قطع كثيرون
منهم الشك اخيرا في تخاذل المجتمع الدولي
عن واجب انقاذهم بيقين تواطئه ضدهم
للروايه هنا صيغتان اولاهما تفترض فصل
الانساني عن السياسي لتدعو الى مساعده
المنكوبين باعتبارهم ضحايا كارثه طبيعيه
وفي معزل عن كل ما سبقها من صراعات بين
نظام الحكم والثائرين عليه بينما تتحدث
الثانيه عن سياق من الكوارث السياسيه التي
القت بملايين السوريين بين انياب الزلزال
الجيولوجي وليس من الحكمه تجاهلها عند
الحديث عن وجهه عمليات الاغاثه
[تصفيق]
كان لابد والحال هذه من الم الانتظار
بكلفته البشريه الباهظه حتى يكتمل سيناريو
الاحداث على ارض الواقع ويصل الى نتيجه
الفاجعه التي قد لا تختلف عليها الروايات
في اليوم الاول وقع الزلزال المدمر وتحدثت
الانباء عن ضحايا باعداد من خانتين او
ثلاث في اليوم الثاني صارت الخانات اربعه
وفي الثالث هبت عشرات الدول لارسال فرق
الاغاثه الى تركيا ثم في الرابع بدا
المنكوبون في شمال غرب سوريا يدركون ان
مناطقهم مستثناه من رافت العالم التزاما
بقرارات سابقه كانت توافقت عليها الدول
الكبرى في الامم المتحده حول طرق ارسال
المعونات اليهم ومع حلول اليوم الخامس
تعالت التساؤلات عن عدد الايام التي
يستطيع الانسان فيها ان يبقى على قيد
الحياه من دون ماء او غذاء
عند هذا الجزء المروع من السيناريو سيطل
فاصل سياسي قصير وقد يقال ان قليلا من
السياسه لن يزيد كميه الركام على اجساد
الناس المطمورين تحت انقاذ بيوتهم في شمال
غرب سوريا ولن يقلل كميه الاكسجين التي
نضبت لديهم او تكاد غير انه قد ينفع في
مساعده الباقين على قيد الحياه هناك ومن
يتعاطفون معهم على رؤيه ما يتوارى من
اجزاء الصوره وراء الركام وهي اجزاء ستظهر
فيها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي غزت
العراق واحتلت برغم انف الدول الكبرى
والصغرى في الامم المتحده قد صارت تتحجج
منذ سنين بالفيديو الروسي في مجلس الامن
الدولي لتمتنع ومعها بقيه الدول الغربيه
عن ادخال كيس من الاغذيه والادويه الى
شمال غرب سوريا الا بموافقه الكرملين اما
العرب او اكثريه انظمه حكمهم فما عاد
لديهم هم فيما يتعلق بالشان السوري سوى
تعويم الرئيس بشار الاسد حتى ولو على دم
ضحايا الزلزال في حين اصبحت الدول
الاقليميه الكبرى تتلاقى ايضا على الموقف
نفسه او لا تعترض عليه وان كان لكل منها
سببه مختلف تركيا تنكفئ على معالجات
نصيبها من الزلزال عشيه انتخاباتها
المرتقبه في ايار مايو المقبل وايران
تواصل التمسك بموقفها في نصره نظام الحكم
واسرائيل التي حظيت بجبهه هادئه في
الجولان طوال خمسه عقود من حكم ال الاسد
والمحكومه اليوم بيمين دينيا متطرف تعتبر
بلسان حاخاماتها ان ما حدث عقاب الهي
للمسلمين بعربهم واتراكهم على حد سواء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بالعوده الى سيناريو الاحداث ومع حلول
اليوم السادس لن يسيخ العالم سمعه لتساؤل
الوف السوريين عن عدد الخيانات الكبرى
التي يمكن للضمير الانساني ان يبقى بعدها
على قيد الحياه وفي السابع او الثامن او
التاسع ستطوى صفحه الموت السوري ويعود
ساده الكون ليستانفوا خطط ايصال مساعدات
عسكريه بمليارات الدولارات الى اوكرانيا
حتى تنتصر على الغزو الروسي وطبعا تحت
شعارات قيميه عنوانها الانتصار للحق في
مواجهه الباطل
من ريفي ادلب معنا خديجه محمد خطيب
المتطوعه بالدفاع المدنيه السوريه مرحبا
بك خديجه اخبرينا عما يواجهوا الدفاع
المدني السوري في شمال غرب سوريا من
تحديات في هذا الوقت
مرحبا بكم جميعا عند البدايه الرحله
لشهدائنا وقتدانا الزلزال
ودعائنا بالشفاء العاجل
جرحانا بسبب الكارثه اما عنا وضعنا نحن
البيضاء حاليا على الارض صراحه وضعنا
يعني وضعنا كتير صعب الاحساسنا بعدم
قدرتنا على انقاذ
الاشخاص كانوا تحت الانقاذ ولسه فينا نروح
وحاطين امل نحن فينا كمتطوعين في الدفاع
المدني وعمال انساني قد انه نوصل لالهم
فاحنا عايشين مرحله كتير صعبه ولحد الان
نحن لسه بدانا بمرحله البحث والانتشار
للمتوفين بهاي الكارثه فالوضع صراحه صعب
يعني بداتم بمرحله البحث وانتشال
المتوفيين يعني وكان
الدفاع المدني قد
فقد الامل
بوجود احياء او على الاقل بالقدره على
انقاذ من يمكن ان يكونوا على قيد الحياه
تحت الانقاض
الصراحه بعد سته ايام وقوع كارثه الزلزال
مع ضعف في وجود الاليات والكارسي كانت
كثير كبيره في مدن متعدده وقعت كلياتها
كانت بنايات فكل الاضرار كانت كثير كبيره
على الاف من المدنيين الدفاع المدني
استجاب فورا وحاول انه يكون مسيطر وسير
الموقف ولكن غلبنا الوقت فنحن خسرنا فعليا
الساعات الاولى 72 الذهبي ووجهنا كتير
نداءات نحن بحاجه لاليات ثقيل بحاجه
لمعدات حتى نقدر نوصل للاشخاص اللي عم
تنتظرنا الاشخاص اللي عم نسمع صوتهم
الاشخاص اللي عم يستنجدوا فينا ولكن للاسف
يعني
هاي المعدات مين الشخص القادر على انه
يبقى تحت الانقاض بدون اكل او شرب مصاب او
عم ينزف او عنده متلازمه الهرسه ايام
عايش بهذه الاجواء فنحن عم نحكي عن شيء
مستحيل صراحه
تضغط عن يعني
مع الاسف مع الاسف نحن فرق بحث وانقاذ
تحولنا الى فرق بحث وانتشال بسبب الكارثه
اللي مرت
طيب يعني لا ادري ان كانت لديك معلومات
لكن هناك من يتحدث عن
امكانيه الوصول
فريق من الهلال الاحمر الى منطقه ادلب يوم
غد هل لديكم معلومات هل ترددت هذه
المعلومات امامكم هل علمتم بامكانيه وصول
مساعدات غدا الى ادلب
نحن بنعرف انه في مساعدات راح توصل لادلب
بتخص المتضررين من حادثه الزلزال ولكن نحن
كدفاع مدني لحد الان ما حدا نسق معنا
بموضوع الوصول
لمساعده او انقاذ او انتشال
فالموضوع يعني لحد الان ما تم التنسيق
معنا في وانما المساعدات اللي عم نسمع
انها رح تدخل فهي عباره عن مساعدات
للمتضررين من الزلزال وطبعا نحن نتشكر كل
الاهل
والاقارب والمجتمع المدني والمجتمع القطري
والسعودي اللي ساهموا بهذه المساعدات وهاي
المسانده والمتبرعين اللي اللي من وجههم
كثير شكر على هاي المساندات اللي يعني
كانت فارقه مع اهلنا الموجودين
شكرا لك يا خديجه محمد خطيب المتطوعه
بالدفاع المدني السوري في ادلب
هذا وتواجه الكوادر الطبيه في مناطق شمال
غربيه سوريا تحديات كبيره بسبب زياده عدد
المصابين جراء الزلزال وكان قطاع الصحفي
المنطقه قد عانى طويلا بسبب تدمير
المستشفيات بشكل مستمر جراء قصف قوات
النظام وروسيا
مراسلنا رصد الاوضاع في مستشفى سامز في
باب الهوى واعدى تقرير التالي
في اصعب موقف يمكن ان يمر به اب وام
يلتقيان ابنتهما قبل نقلها الى غرفه
العمليات
حيره وذهول قبل اتخاذ القرار المر فعلى
الاب ان يوافق على بتر ساق ابنته التي
اصيبت في الزلزال وقتل ولداها
بعد انهيار منزلهم في مدينه حارم
هل
هي مردومه من هون
والحمد لله ما رايت وهلا اجره ميته بده
يبترول
اكتظت اقسام المستشفى بالمرضى وذويهم ما
يعني مزيدا من الضغط على الكوادر الطبيه
قد خلفت اثار الزلزال قصصا لم يعتدوها مثل
وجود رضيع ماتت كل عائلته او جريح لا
يستطيع المستشفى مساعدته لاسباب يوضحها
الطبيب احمد الذي كان في المستشفى لحظه
الزلزال
ما احسننا يعني نقدم احسن خدمه لكل المرضى
بسبب نقص
المستلزمات الطبيه الموجوده وخاصه انه نحن
خلال فتره طويله من الحرب يعني تم استهلاك
اغلب المواد وكان في علينا كتير ضغوط
وخاصه فيما بعد وقت اللي صار عنا بعض
الجراحات العصبيه مثل تثبيت الفقرات اللي
احنا بالاساس ما عنا مثلا مواد استجدال
لتثبيت فقرات او للكسور العظمي اكمل
الزلزال وما بداته الحرب من احداث اكبر
ضرر بالقطاع الصحي
فتصدع مستشفى الامومه بعد الزلزال اجبر
منظمه سامز على اخلائه بشكل كامل عندما
كان الناس في امس الحاجه اليه
رغم مرور ايام على الزلزال في سوريا ما
زالت المستشفيات تغص بالجرحى ولا يشغل بال
الاطباء حال المرضى فقط بل تامين الادويه
والمستلزمات الطبيه ايضا في ظل ضعف
المساعدات الدوليه التي تصل المنطقه صهيب
الخلف الجزيره ريف ادلب
من شمال غرب سوريا معنى دكتور امجد راس
رئيس الجمعيه الطبيه السوريه الامريكيه
دكتور مرحبا بك كيف يتم التغلب على
المشاكل والمصاعد التي تواجه
القطاع الطبي بعد هذا الزلزال وقد تبعنا
يعني عينات
منه في التقرير الذي قدم
السلام عليكم شكرا اخوتي الحقيقه انا سمعت
نهايه التقرير
كان موضوعا نقص بعض الطبيه خاصه بتثبيت
الفقرات
واغلاق مشفى احد مشيد في سوريا توليد
توليد الاطفال
الوضع اول شيء نحن
لا تزال المشافي المغلقه مغلقه بسبب
الدمار التي لحق بها
وعدم كفاءتها او عدم سلامتها لان يكون
فيها اي عمل طبي من الناحيه المعماريه
نقص المستهلكات
لا يزال قائم خاصه
المستهلكات التي تخص
العمليات العظميه وعمليات العصبيه وتثبيت
الفقرات طبعا اللي شفناه بالزلزال هو سقوط
اوزان ثقيله جدا من
صفائح الكونكريت الاسمنت
الاجسام تعرض لك الصوره من مختلفه بما
فيها كسور جمجمه كسور الاطراف وكسور
العمود الفقري كسور العمود الفقري خطيره
جدا نحن لم
نكنقطاع طبي
مجهزين لهذا العدد من تثبيت الفقرات او او
هذه الكم الهائل
من الاصابات العصبيه والعظميه التي تاتي
كلها عفوا تاتي كلها في وقت وزن عفوا ضمن
تاتي كلها في ضمن
فايق زمني لا تجاوز لعده ساعات طبعا هذا
بدايه
الاستجابه
للزلزال وعمليات الاوقات لازال نعاني من
النقص طيب لازلتم تعانون من هذا النقص
هل جربتم الاتصال بهيئات دوليه هيئات طبيه
اغاثيه للحصول على على هذه الحاجات الملحه
في حالات
الزلزال طبعا هناك الكثير من المصابين
ياتون وهم يحتاجون اليها
نحن اللي حصل الان كان مختلف جدا عن ما
كان يحصل يحصل في الماضي في الماضي كانت
الاصابات يقول قصف على منطقه سكنيه او او
تجمع من المواطنين على مخبز او
سوق شعبيه
وقت اللي بينقصنا مستهلكات نحن كنا نجيبها
من تركيا
الان الوضع في تركيا ببعض مناطق تركيا
خاصه الحدوديه
اسوا من بعض المناطق في سوريا
الناس
المسؤولين
هن ملتهين او او مشغولين على اهاليهم
الوضع الوضع انه بدنا
المسعف يسعفنا والمسعف يحتاج ان يصرفه
فتواصلنا مع المنظمات الدوليه طبعا تم من
البدايه
نعم بس لاسباب لوجستيه لم تفتح الحدود الا
الا البارحه
الاحد بعد نص الليل يعني يوم الجمعه تم
فتح الحدود بس لحد الان لم نرى
المستهلكاتها
شكرا لك دكتور امجد راس رئيس الجمعيه
الطبيه السوريه الامريكيه من شمال غربيه
سوريا
مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في تغطيه تدعيه
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا سنعود
للمتابعه مجددا لكن بعد وقفه قصيره مع
اخبار اخرى
قالت الاداره الاقليميه الاوكرانيه في
دينيبرو الشرقيه البلاد انها سيارات روسيه
هجمت ثلاث منشات للطاقه في منطقتي كريفي
ما ادى الى اندلاع حرائق وذكرت الاداره
الاقليميه ان منشاه في منطقه
هجمت مرتين في يوم واحد ما اسفر عندما رن
كبير
اكد وزير او نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
ان موسكو ستكون مستعده للتفاوض مع كييفو
ولكن دون شروط مسبقه وعلى اساس الواقع
القائم واوضح ان القرار بشان المفاوضات في
يد بروكسل وواشنطن وليس لدى كييف
افاد فلسطينيون يقتلون في ضاحيه جبل
المكبر في القدس المحتله ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي سلمتهم اختارات بهدم منازلهم
خلال الايام المقبله بل سيؤدي الى تشريد
نحو 120 مواطنا واكدوا ان قوه حرس الحدود
سلمتهم الاخطارات اليوم بذريعه ان منازلهم
لم تحصل على تراخيص من السلطات يذكر ان
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار
بنغفير اعلن عن خطه لمضاعفه عدد منازل
الفلسطينيين غير الشرعيه حسبت تعبيره
والتي سيشرع في هدمها